il ya certains smartphones qui
lorsqu'ils sortent à créer l'intérêt
crée la tension est créée la curiosité
ça fait moins parce qu'il propose
quelque chose d'innovant alors c'est
vrai que dans cette pléiade de
smartphones avec toute cette concurrence
tous ces modèles qui existent
il ya un petit moment certains modèles
se ressemblent et l'innovation pas
toujours là et quand on arrive à choper
quelques smartphones avec de
l'innovation dedans oui je fais bien le
trait d'atr qui échappe le smartphone et
bien c'est libre a coulé justement
l'agent smartphones avec une belle
innovation smartphones qui est
intéressant qui peut créer d'autres
usages en tout cas qui peut être
améliorée des usages déjà existants
c'est celui là un smartphone que vous ne
connaissez peut-être pas une marque que
vous ne connaissez peut-être pas cellule
via le mode lcd et devint garder ses
marques juste là il coule est vraiment
cool parce qu'il faut pas d'innovations
majeures qui est très intéressante c'est
là vous avez un écran et hop vous avez
un deuxième écran on a un écran de
chaque côté on peut faire plein de
choses avec ça crée des usages c'est
intéressant je vous explique ça tout de
suite
[Musique]
avant d'aller plus loin dans la vidéo je
demanderai deux choses la première c'est
de vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà
fait comme ça vous saurez tout sur
l'actu technologique smartphones et
compagnie et puis le deuxième point
c'est à votre avis qu'est-ce que c'est
double écran le fait d'avoir un écran
ici et le fait d'avoir un écran ici
qu'est ce que ces douze l'écran peuvent
vous apporter comme un avantage
qu'est ce que ça peut avoir comme
intérêt marqué moi tout ça en bas congo
terme et et la pose de cliquer sur pause
vous marquez vous revenez et on verra à
la fin si on est raccord oui ou non à
les imiter pose ses membres et me pose
pour peut y aller aïoli barre avant même
de regarder plus et d'en voir plus à ce
smartphone on va faire un tour du côté
de la boîte bon la boîte en elle même
vouloir aller comme ça elle paraît pas
complètement dingue
allez classica les standards mais voyons
voir ce qu à l'intérieur c'est souvent
là haut up vernon qui l'a pas qu'on
appelle surprise qu'est ce qu'on a ici
de quoi ouvrir votre tiroir de cartes
sim on a une coque alors ça c'est
surprenant parce que petit protection
assas mans c'est une protection pour
l'ariège dont vous pouvez vous dire ok
soit je vais mettre ma petite protection
ici les envoyer le petit trou pour le
capteur qui est planqué je ne sais où tu
mon probablement ici mais si vous voulez
pas avoir ça ici et là rien de beau
smartphone et bien vous pouvez utiliser
cette petite coque alors la coque
elle al'avantage effectivement devient
le protégé lorsque vous allez lui poser
par contre elle a l'inconvénient est
bien c'est que vous ayez une coque voyez
sans votre écran arrière alors on le
voit quand même un normalement devenir
manipuler si je viens débrouiller je
peux quand même venir l'utiliser c'est
pas très très beau on voit quand même ça
remplit son usage il ya un mois sacré
des petits points dessus je trouve pas
ça hyper kalisa vient le protège un peu
pour moi la meilleure solution là dessus
c'est très clairement d'avoir un bumper
comme ça ça vous ne protège que le poser
sur la face avant sur la face arrière et
vous profitez vraiment de la meilleure
qualité d'écran d'un côté comme de
l'autre
une fois qu'on a faim c'est ça qu'est ce
qu'on a ici on a de la documentation
carte de garantie est un modèle européen
j'ai donc ça c'était vraiment le
smartphone était planquée ici ils
venaient directement
ensuite on va avoir des accessoires ici
dans cette grosse grosse boîte câble
cette couleur sont est choquant sawan
plus moi c'est très très drôle usb c'est
usb aux caisses affectionne adaptateur
usb sévère prise jack parce que vous
n'avez pas de prise galles sur le
smartphone donc si vous voulez écouter
de la musique vous branchez ça vaut
brancher un casque pour moi c'est pas
pratique mais bon voilà c'est là
pourquoi pas ça existe ensuite ça se
passe de l'autre côté on retrouve ici
son bloc de charge 27 watts pour venir
recharger son smartphone rapide bon
voilà on a fait le tour
voilà un peu tout ce qu'il ya du point
de vue packaging mort et irène bien
et il ya juste l'essentiel c'est quelque
chose d'ypres originale qui a fait du
bien là dessus d'avoir ce smartphone là
avec deux écrans si je le pense comme ça
j'ai l'écran d'un mois et si je le pense
comme ça j'ai l'écran vers moi alors
enfin il ya différentes possibilités
différentes configurations de l'écran en
fonction de ce que vous allez voir faire
vous allez voir tout le monde ça se
passe à l'intérieur au niveau de l'ouest
mais avant toute chose on va faire un
petit tour du point de vue esthétique
vorskla parce que quelques pas mal de
petites particularités là dessus des
choses qu on ne s'attendrait pas à voir
s'ils ont remarqué que pour le contenu
via a osé faire dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire me sens
quand même très original d'avoir ce
smartphone avec un grand écran sans rien
sans caméra pop up sans caméra qui se
relève swiss sans rien juste un écran la
caméra est à l'arrière la caméra est
uniquement l'arrière mais c'est tout
l'adn de ce smartphone c'est à dire que
vous avez votre caméra à l'arrière qui
sert de caméras de scènes filmées qui
sert aussi de cannes est la principale
c'est un vrai parti pris pour le coup
c'est vraiment très très très malin et
l'idée d'avoir installé un écran en
arrière c'est pas mal en fait regardez
la particularité vous l'avez là c'est
que sur le côté ici vous avez votre
capteur d'empreintes digitales
vous avez votre bouton volume et si vous
tournez votre smartphone vous avez
également votre capteur d'empreintes
digitales et là vous avez toujours de
cartes sim double viennent aussi mais
capteur d'empreintes digitales d'un côté
de l'autre dans deux raisons la première
c'est que lorsque vous tenez comme ça et
bien vous allez pouvoir venir le
déverrouiller et vous avez accès d
actualiser votre smartphone hop hop je
l'éteins je le tourne et lorsque je dis
comme ça
j'appuie taxe à déverrouiller et ça
marche de ce côté là donc ça c'est cool
ça marche également pour les droitiers
les pour les gauchers ça c'est
extrêmement rare qu'on ait pensé aux
gauchers du coup ça permet double usage
droitier gaucher écran avant écran ria
pour les verrouiller c'est extrêmement
flexible en plus que j'aime bien
qu'entre pas partout c'est le capteur
d'empreintes digitales c'est également
un bouton donc ça me permet de l'allumer
ça me permet de l'étain très facilement
de faire comme je veux jamais en plus il
est extrêmement réactif ça marche très
très bien en dessous après votre parleur
mono de la recharge ici directement en
usb c'est le micro vous avez un micro
pour la réduction brute et planck est
ici sur le dessus après vous avez des
capteurs s'ils voulaient avoir
différentes actions par exemple je
presse l'a simplement mode une main je
fais un appui long ça me fait une
capture d'écran on peut le paramétrer je
vous montre dans quelques instants mais
surtout ce qui est vraiment intéressante
smartphones ce sont les deux écrans deux
écrans amoled ça quand je les ai reçus
au début je me suis dit ok ok il nous
met à l'écran mal de l'avant ça marche
mais l'arrière on avec dali ps on a du
lcd et bien non pas du tout à l'avant
vous avez d'écran de 6,42 poussée de
l'amoled 2340 par 1080 pixels ratio de
19 points 5/9 corning gorilla glass 5 à
l'avant pour le protéger plutôt bien et
à l'arrière vous avez également un écran
amoled 5
dulin pouces c'est beaucoup plus petit
forcément mais pas beaucoup de place à
l'écran qui vous servira surtout on dire
faire mon photo vous allez voir il y
aussi de tout ce qu'on peut faire 1520
par 720 pixels ratio 19/9 corning
gorilla glass 5 également et un écran
qui a été travaillé pour la réduction de
lumière bleue je vous montre l'ouest
rapidement on est basé sur un android
neuf on a un hub ya eu ouailles mais
bien hoa il est pas mal mais il est pas
où en fait tanguer quelques soucis
notamment au niveau de la traduction
toutes les parties qui sont dédiés ne
sont pas traduites super i-care fonds ne
s'est quant à lui inscrit
bon bah tout de suite ce qu'on diaries
screen space switch vitrine to screen ce
qui est quand même quelques petites
choses qui n'ont pas été complètement
traduite alors vous le comprenez même si
vous maîtrisez pas la langue de
shakespeare si vous menez foule ici et
pas mal de possibilités super eye care
for seconde argos queen ce conte d'alice
queen c'est ici on vient donc se mettre
ici on retourne dans nos paramètres qui
sont juste là t'as qu'on vient ici et à
pouvoir venir paramètres un peu cet
écran un peu plus médium super et les
couverts sont pas de la villa noailles
et vous venez de régler un petit peu
comme vous voulez la basique ça va quand
même fort light sa vie un petit peu
limité le côté bleu un peu moins
agressif médium c'est pas mal c'est
packard et dell moi je le mords light ça
fonctionne
ensuite vous retrouverez le second mari
screen space là c'est assez marrant
parce que vous allez pouvoir venir
vraiment paramétrer votre deuxième écran
on la voyait dû inscrire multi tasking
donc là j'ai pu voir une tâche ici je
vais tourner si gérard une deuxième
tâche voyez hop je retourne la chanteuse
sur ma tâche je retourne derrière je
retourne ici
par contre je te dire ensuite si je le
souhaite que j'ai un mode miroir c'est
que j'ai exactement la même chose du
côté d'autres sa gelée là je tourne
enfin trouvé exactement la même chose
voyez up paf je switche là ça c'est
pratique donc ça dépend effectivement de
vos usages ça dépend effectivement ce
que vous voulez en faire aussi vous avez
un mode qui est assez marrant c'est le
swiss between tous queen's alors ça
c'est vraiment bien et c'est en tout cas
un des usages le plus intéressant pour
moi ça vous montre comment vous allez
switcher soir mode automatique sorbonne
manuel ramon manuel regarder s'avoue
rajoute ici une petite icône de pouvoir
venir déplacer quand vous naviguez vous
l'avez toujours sous les yeux sont pas
sa taille et par contre vous cliquez ça
vous le dis vous tournez vous le
retrouvez vous cliquez vous retournez au
paf vous retrouver bon c'est assez
intuitif c'est pas très très beau je
privilégie quand même plutôt de me
retrouver avec l'option automatique
c'est à dire que je prends je tourne up
sa meule et ça ne le remet ça marche
après avoir un petit bouton pour le look
et hop la joc je peux le tourner sa
tombe pas je reviens là du coup j'ai
bougé avec mon doigt
le doc je tourne ça revient là ça moi
j'enlève parce qu'une fois de plus les
icônes sur l'écran ça m'embête et la
dixième ce qui est marrant c'est le
screen wakeup qui vous dira ce qu'il va
se passer à ce que vous aller allumer
votre smartphone
alors là haut up paf jolie de mon
smartphone eh bien je tombe sur mon
écran principal que je l'aide d'un côté
ou que gelée de l'autre je tombe
toujours sur l'autre écran ensuite j'ai
une autre possibilité je peux dire
correspondance queen c'est ce que
j'avais mis moi donc je viens dans
l'allumé en fonction de l'écran sur
lequel je suis bien voyez cet écran qui
va s'allumer plutôt que l'autre donc bon
ça ça marche aussi
ensuite il faut choisir soit le premier
écran l'écran principal soit l'écran
secondaire chenaux cassignac lorsque
j'ai lu il ya un des deux écrans qui va
s'allumer
par exemple la up je l'éteins je
l'allumé bien c'est le deuxième écran
c'est l'écran derrière qui s'allument
bon c'est vous qui règle et peut
vraiment faire ce que vous voulez c'est
ce que je trouve intéressant après ça
dépend bien évidemment des usages de
vous ce que vous voulez en faire moi ce
qui me correspond c'est sa
correspondante screen ensuite vous avez
le prêcheur border ce qui peut expliquer
c'est ce que vous allez venir toucher
ici et bien c'est les petits raccourcis
là vous appuyer sa part une naviguer à
une main parce que l'écran quand même
très très grande
et lorsque je fais un appui long et bien
je fais une capture d'écran ça c'est à
paramétrer pour le paramétrer ses hypra
simple hop ça peut soit fermée tenir à
une main voir le centre de notifications
allumer ou éteindre le flash de faire
une capture d'écran ou alors ouvrir une
application que j'aurais paramétrer ici
peut régler exactement la même chose
pour l'appui l'on voyait donc sur le
principe c'est assez marrant je peux
rêver aussi le niveau de pression que je
souhaite vous avez aussi le always on
display
c'est un petit peu standard ça vous
mettra ce que vous pouvez avoir
effectivement l'horloge digitale
critique compagnie fait plus tout ça
reste en anglais toutes les parties se
dirait nubie hawaï est en anglais toute
la partie android est en france et vous
vous retrouvez accessibilité google
système etc etc etc
au niveau de l'affichage aussi vous avez
quelques petites préférences une fois de
plus les préférences ça vous marque en
anglais display préférence colorful mode
natural mod
à vous de voir que leur tout le mode ça
fonctionne il n'y a pas beaucoup de
réglages au niveau de l'écran n'est pas
complètement ouf
mais ça fonctionne tout l'intérêt de
smartphones réside vraiment au niveau
des deux écrans des usages de ce que
vous allez pouvoir en faire de l'intérêt
que ça apporte
si c'est juste pour avoir deux écrans
pour nos écrans pour se la péter devant
les copains ça sert strictement pas à
grand chose
vous avez effectivement un bel écran ici
vous a effectivement un écran de rien
qui est un peu moins ou simplement
brillant simplement prendre si c'est un
peu moins sympa ça fait le taf on n'est
plus un petit moniteur
je vous montre on peut faire des choses
intéressantes notamment au niveau de la
photo si vous voulez regarder des séries
sur netflix là dessus ou sur youtube et
bien là des eaux plutôt bien qu'un peu
moins de reflets si vous êtes
extrêmement courageux et courageuses
c'est pas qu'un peu plus d'un an par
contre l'écran ici la qualité elle est
vraiment cool pour tout le côté
multimédia ça fonctionne nous a quand
même un grand écran ça c'est vraiment
hyper agréable nous une qualité qui est
aussi intéressant c'est la qualité c'est
une ville d'audio vous avez un haut
parleur mono qui se situe là je trouve
que déjà comme ça le doryphore l'audio
est puissant vous avez vraiment quelque
chose qui est très agréable pour
l'écouter comme ça moi ce que je vous
conseille apprécié de mettre un case up
la cgt toi monsieur vous en baisse un
peu le son cnet un casque bluetooth
parce que vous êtes du bluetooth 5
points en intérieur sans aucun problème
ce par une fois profité de la meilleure
expérience en termes de divertissement
et quand on parle divertissement parle
aussi gaming vous avez différents enjeux
qui sont là dessus mais surtout vous
allez tout s'appelle le games day ce qui
vous permet de profiter d'une expérience
vraiment augmenté en termes de jeu donc
là vous avez vos jeux qui sont installés
à ce fatras yann accompagner sa up
regardez moi je suis pas les deux
joueurs jouent mais sur ce jeu là bon
bon vieux asphalte 9
l'expérience est vraiment super et
derrière cela vous avez la performance
de battre un dragon 855 plus les giga de
ram 128 giga de stockage ça roule ça
fonctionne et vous avez un très gros
score selon tutto de 475 milles c'est
énorme c'est un smartphone qui est
extrêmement performant vous avez ici
dans votre game center pas mal de
possibilités vous allez pouvoir venir
enregistrer votre écran en faire des
captures d'écran et lorsque vous jouez à
des jeux hop tout seul sur le côté il a
vous avez toutes les informations
température du smartphone vous avez vos
infos au niveau de votre bande passante
gpu cpu automod toutes les touches faire
des photos pouey bloquer les messages ya
pas mal de possibilités ça s'est
vraiment bien nous mourons street le
gaming chose qui se développe énormément
au niveau des smartphones l'autonomie
aussi excellentes avec une grosse
batterie de 4000 millions terreur vous
tenez un jour et demi deux jours ça
dépendra plus des usa se défend pas mal
de choses ça dépend notamment de vos
réglages au niveau de votre écran
notamment des paramètres même lorsque
vous allez venir jouer en mode jeu vous
avez la possibilité d'avoir
effectivement votre jeu à l'avant et
aussi d'avoir un petit écran arrière
pour venir vous la péter
ça c'est bien ça sert pas à grand chose
et ça consomme beaucoup mais sinon un
jour et mis 2 jours vous les avez vous
avez laroche charge rapide dans les
paramètres vous avez un autre qui est
marrante crime scene lie effect regardez
ça c'est rigolo
en fait ça vous permettre de venir avoir
un effet sur votre écran rire lorsque
vous allez utiliser votre smartphone par
exemple que quelqu'un de passer un coup
de fil up paf
effectivement il peut augmenter la
consommation
de la batterie et bien vous allez
pouvoir choisir ce qui va s'afficher par
exemple vous avez un coup de fil
hop sa fiche est la matrice derrière bon
ça ça ne parlera plus rigolo mais
pourquoi pas mais lorsque vous jouez
bien vous pouvez activer et là vous avez
le choix entre différentes choses cette
petite chose là avec le processeur
snapdragon 855 plus je manque un truc
vous allez voir ça sert pas à grand
chose
oui lorsque j'ai dans mon jeu s'affiche
ici qualcomm snapdragon 155 alors ça
consomme de l'énergie derrière ça
disparaît saluer de temps en temps c'est
juste histoire de venir un petit peu se
la péter bon c'est rigolo mais ça
apporte pas grand chose maintenant il ya
d'autres usages qui est rigolo c'est au
niveau de la partie photo ça ne vous
aura peut-être pas échappé vous avez
trois capteurs photos ici deux flash led
pourquoi pas premier capteur 14
principales qui est planqué ici c'est
une caméra de 48 mégapixels certains de
sony mx 5 186 à une otite ouvre à f
1.7 une stabilisation optique vous avez
un côté une caméra de 5 mégapixels salle
ultra grand-angle 222 2 degrés oui s'il
vous plaît ouvre à f 2.2 il vous avez un
téléobjectif 8 mégapixels avec un zoom
optique x 3 et un zoom numérique jusqu'à
x 30 x 30 très mal aux yeux jusqu'à x 10
et bien au delà ça fait un petit peu mal
ouverture f 2.4 et s'il n'y a pas du
tout stabilisation optique et vous vous
en douterez comme on a un écran derrière
on n'a pas de caméra de saïfi il n'y a
pas de caméra qui souffre pas de caméra
pop-up battre qui souffre pas de tiroirs
side ici tout se situe là l'idée c'est
que justement lorsque vous allez ouvrir
votre smartphone vous allez vouloir
faire des photos si vous voulez passer
en caméra cette fille est bien claque
vous appuyer là vous tournez votre
smartphone et là vous arrivez ici tout
simplement voilà l'intérêt cet écran
c'est effectivement là de pouvoir vous
voir lorsque vous allez faire des photos
alors ça c'est première usage
c'est effectivement les rigolos vous
répugnez up paf pour tourner de l'autre
côté donc ça c'est marrant mais aussi
une autre possibilité
vous cliquez là voyez et ça va activer
le deuxième écran donc lorsque vous
allez prendre quelqu'un en photo là par
exemple je la comprendre mais en photo
eh bien voyez je me vois j'ai pas les
boutons tu peux pas appuyer par contre
ça fait un petit moniteur donc là
quelqu'un en face qui va me prendre trop
tôt je peux boire sur les jolies bottes
et salut c moi ça permet de vous parler
directement les yeux dans les yeux et ça
c'est cool à garder et lorsque je
retourne ici
eh bien voyez j'ai ma caméra principale
il faut seulement savoir que si les
ricains notre côté eh bien il verrait
cette partie là vient cette partie là
verrez cette partie là vous verriez cet
écran la renverrait les deux c'est assez
rigolo
donc ça je trouve que c'est un usage qui
est assez marrant c'est pas complètement
dingue mais c'est assez marrant alors
après pour vous parler simplement d'une
question de logiciels fois un x 3 x 5 x
10 si vous voulez monter encore plus
loin vous venez pensez vous
zoomer ou dézoomer comme ça et vous avez
ensuite l'ultra grand-angle fois 06 ça
marche après vous êtes un mode propre ou
switcher entre les différentes caméras
caméras faits me laisse quelques petites
options expositions multiples pouvoirs
territoriaux comme il ya pas mal de
possibilités c'est pas dingue mais s'ils
sentent vous marrer si vous le souhaitez
vous avez de la vidéo la vidéo c'est
intéressant vous avez quand même une
stabilisation qui pas mal là dessus mais
surtout au niveau des options et c'est
assez surprenant
vous pouvez filmer jusqu'en 8 k oui
jusqu'à huit cas en bêta il voulut
marque bien utiliser uniquement à
l'extérieur
huit cas à 15 images par seconde alors
je vous montre est ok pas ouvrir une
petite vidéo unique avoir sa définition
et des regardeurs monsieur ici je crois
qu'il ne faut absolument pas bougé lors
qu'on a filmé on habitait ici pour avoir
la meilleure définition mais dans
l'absolu pourquoi pas tout voir mais lui
qui a devant le poste de l'a8 qui
apparaît ici c'est plutôt cool europe
les résultats la france pour trouver le
produit fichiers quel poids va faire
ficher il va peser très lourd voire pas
du tout 271 méga octet la vidéo we can
apporte pas grand-chose sur pas grand
chose
elle n'est pas stabilisée les résultats
est pas terrible pour moi c'est un coup
de com c'est rigolo mais ça oubliez vous
voyez moi quelques photos photos prises
avec le capteur principal tout coup
c'est pas mal le 48 mégapixels plutôt
bien stabilisé ça c'est intéressant ça
fonctionne le résultat est bon zoom x 3
là on commence par un ultra grand-angle
caméra principale d'une différence au
niveau de la colorimétrie si vous le
voyez au niveau du bâtiment là il est un
peu plus jaune là il y a un petit peu
moins depuis naturel comme ça zoom x 3 x
5 x dit ce que je reproche il n'y a pas
de stabilisation au niveau du thé
objectif donc d'où tout de suite dès que
je bouge bien ça soit forcément bon pas
de mika avec le mode portrait et voyez
ça fonctionne pas mal le détourage et
pas trop trop mal là il a eu un petit
peu de mal j'ai l'impression issue mais
non oui on sait on vraiment artificielle
s'est pas complètement fou un haut
niveau de la découpe bon ça fait le taf
on n'a pas non plus utiliser notre
portrait tout le temps ici un petit peu
à contre jour on passe sur l'ultra quand
on est quand même une différence entre
l'ultra d'entendre les le capteur
principal au niveau de la colorimétrie
on continue avec le zoom x 3 x 5 x 2 10
une fois de plus pas de stabilisation
c'est vraiment dommage
il aura fallu moins une stabilisation
électronique là dessus pour que moi ça
ait un sens tout de suite c'est vraiment
dommage il faut quand même y pratiquera
hypra stabilise au niveau de ses mains
caméra principale ultra-grand-angle
toujours et fameuse différence du
colorimétrie x 3 x 5 x 10 pas terrible
caméra principale
utre
entendre différence de colorimétrie
c'est beaucoup plus bleu comme ça on
continue 6 x 3 x 5 x 10 c'est parce
labellisé c'est vraiment dommage par
contre que ce rapprochement les tailles
c'est pas trop mal c'est pas
extraordinaire mais ça fait un petit peu
le taf caméra principale luttera
grand-angle x 3 x 5 x 10 toujours d'un
programme de stabilisation et après il
ya un autre canard en scène mois de
double exposition à lorsque vous faites
et vous prenez la même photo à
différentes expositions faut pas que ça
bouge que sera exactement pareil moi
j'en ai profité pour faire un truc un
petit peu différent petit peu artistique
avec des grandes villes mais je prends
une première photo je bouge un peu
une deuxième photo je trouve ça assez
rigolo ça laissait fait qu'ils sont
assez marrant bon ça fait un peu la
faute aux fantômes mais c'est original
et on peut le faire avec aucun
smartphone en tout cas à ma connaissance
donc fausse assez rigolo comme ça comme
je le disais vous tous à 5.1 double
nanocyl pour l'asie et pour l'europe
vous avez un gps double bande par contre
il n'a pas de certification hyper
résistant à l'eau et à la poussière donc
s'il rencontre un peu d'eau - peu de
poussière et bien on ne sait pas il n'a
pas non plus de recharge sans fil ça me
paraissait normal vu que vous avez un
écran ici vous n'avez pas le recharger
par l'écran c'est vraiment la question
de l'usagé m'intéresse vraiment parce
qu'on est sûr d'avoir d'autres coûte 540
répond je n'ai pas fait l'objet j'en ai
fait ce tournage et celle qui fait
toujours marrer 549 euros
549 euros est ce que ça vaut le coup
alors à 549 euros déjà vous avez un
smartphone qui est extrêmement
performant je trouve qu'il ya des
petites améliorations à voir au niveau
de l'os la surcouche lé pa où il ya des
problèmes de traduction et l'intérêt
premier de smartphones c'est le
paramétrage au niveau de l'écran pouvoir
switcher d'un écran à l'autre
bon ça c'est un petit peu dommage ça
demandera en tout cas être améliorée de
la part du gard
quand on arrive sur un marché comme le
marché français qu'on veut s'adresser à
un public francophone quitte à avoir un
androïde traduit en français autant
voiture rouge qui complètement traduite
ça me paraît en tout cas être la moindre
des choses qui défaut mineur je veux lui
pardonner smartphone extrêmement
puissant smartphone endurant très bon
écran je sens vraiment cool qualité
photo qui est bien je trouve en tout cas
ce smartphone vraiment bien très bien
positionné par rapport à son tarif
maintenant à quoi il vous servira à quoi
vous servir la 12e écran mise à part un
terme aux patates ans je prends en photo
regardent comme des beaufs est ton plus
beau sourire faire plaisir à votre
copine d'instagram meuse n'ont autant
regarder quel toit obtus le voit
derrière mme s'occupera la plus belle
post tu verras c'était vraiment belle
mise à part ça pour le côté photo il ya
un grand intérêt effectivement
d'économiser de la place d'une petite
caméra à l'avant on va économiser une
caméra pop up on va effectivement évité
une encoche une bulle
trouve tout ce que vous voulez votre
appareil photo arrière sera notre
appareil photo principale vous n'avez
qu'un seul module photo par contre il
est extrêmement optimisé je trouve ça
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas ça un sens
pour lui d'avoir une caméra pop up ou
une petite caméra à l'avant qui sera
moins bonne qualité on l'est sur le top
de la qualité en termes de photos et
quel que soit jusque voulait faire même
à celle ci grand temps vous pouvez le 4
donc ça c'est bien ça peut paraître dans
le bon sens surtout sans le faire à la
noble et notamment lorsque vous voulez
faire de la vidéo vous faire des
reportages pourquoi pas et bien vous
pouvez le faire vous posez votre
smartphone adaptateur prise jack pour
brancher un micro dedans vous voyez vous
un moniteur vous filmer avec la
meilleure caméra pour moi ça c'est
vraiment indispensable donc pourquoi pas
dans ce sens là ça peut avoir un sens à
votre média maintenant ce que vous en
pensez comment vous le trouvez ce nubia
z vin bien pas bien est ce qu'il
pourrait vous intéresser au wynn donc on
connaissait l'histoire vous marquez tout
ça en bas en commentaire quant à nous on
se retrouve dès demain pour continuer à
parler texte jean macé à demain châu